For Ken.
[inaudible].
Thanks so much,
Ken.
All right,
I am so excited to,
to be here,
um,
with our guests today.
So my name is Malique do card and uh,
I head up the global family and learning team for a youtube and,
and it's my great honor and pleasure to introduce,
uh,
the man,
the legend,
uh,
Bill.
Nice.
So let's
round of applause
now
around an hour.
And you know,
I could probably spend the whole hour introducing you,
but I'm,
I'll,
I'll spend the whole hour doing that.
Uh,
now how,
oh,
a kickoff with a little bit of intro.
So Bill Nye has been the public face of science for more than 20 years
in his latest book that we'll talk a lot about today.
Everything all at once.
How to unleash your inner nerd,
tap into radical curiosity and solve any problem from Rodale books,
night issues,
a call to arms meant to encourage readers to really become the change they want
to see in the world.
Whether addressing global warming,
social change,
or personal success,
there are certain strategies that always gets results.
Looking at the world with radical curiosity,
being driven by a desire for a better future and being willing to take the
actions needed to make change a reality.
Best known as the host of Emmy Award winning PBS Discovery Channel Show Bill Nye
the Science Scott
and the current home
Netflix show Bill Nye saves the world.
Well that
bill is a science educator,
mechanical engineer in New York Times bestselling author.
He's also the CEO of the Planetary Society that we'll talk about and holds a bs
in mechanical engineering from Cornell and has several doctorate degrees.
So,
uh,
let's talk,
get a warm introduction or welcome to.
Thank you.
Is there any time where that's right.
All right.
So I had the opportunity to,
to read your book,
everything all at once and loved it and I appreciate that.
You know,
a lot of times you get interviewed and they haven't read the book.
That's nice.
Thank you.
Read it,
cover to cover.
And these are your people here.
These are my people,
my,
my kids and why they are not in school today.
What's your why?
I guess so.
Can you tell us what,
what does everything all at once mean?
So we have a great many problems facing humankind.
We have,
when I was
in grade school,
there were 3 billion people.
The world,
now they're almost 7.4 billion by 2050.
There certainly will be nine,
but there may be 10 billion people and they're all going to want access to
Google.
They're all gonna want to live the way we live in the developed world.
So this means we've got to provide clean water.
We're not reliable.
Renewably produced electricity and access to the Internet to everybody.
And that's a big job.
So we got to do everything all at once.
And so along this line,
I,
um,
I just tell her I'm not much for multitasking.
I think the really much as I love all the young people,
I think there really isn't any such thing.
Instead,
you've got to keep in mind everything that has to be done as you accomplish each
task.
Is that yeah,
that,
that's catchy title.
That's catchy.
I'm caught
in reading this book.
It almost seemed like it was,
um,
a manifesto.
Yes.
Uh,
the nerd manifesto manifesto.
That's right.
And do it this way.
It's an activist's book that where's that come from?
And what are you acting on?
Uh,
you want to leave?
There's two things.
Everybody's responsible for his or her own actions.
This is something my dad would say.
And then you want to leave the world better than you found it if you can.
And if we don't hustle,
we going to leave the world a lot worse than we found it.
And so we got to get to work.
So that's why I'm activist.
I mean,
I guess when it comes to things like scientific literacy,
that seems like an obvious thing to be in favor of because it enables companies
like that,
like this to change the world.
Uh,
and it also enables a country like the United States to remain competitive
economically because a innovation,
which is what you guys are all about.
But then you would think that climate change would not be anything to argue
about.
It would be something to get to work on.
Yet.
Uh,
we have this amazing contingent or segment of our society that's in denial about
climate change because of the success of the climate deniers.
They had been so influential.
Three.
It's really amazing.
Yeah.
So that's why I wrote this book.
Let's go.
That's right.
When did we down at one o'clock you guys will be,
you'll have it all set up by one 30.
We'll have all the order too.
It'll be done.
And what,
why do you think that there are so many deniers?
Because the fossil fuel industry,
yeah.
I mean,
that's not rocket surgery,
you guys,
that fossil fuel industry is just really throwing money at the problem and
influence their congressmen representatives,
not just tactically and,
uh,
by sending specious materials and stuff to the congressional step,
but strategically working statewide or Commonwealth wide and Kentucky,
Tennessee and so on,
to the point where you don't,
it's no trouble at all to meet people go,
I don't know if climate change really happening.
Yeah,
it really is.
Yeah.
So a,
it's a big problem and it's,
it's almost unique to United States.
There's very few climate deniers and other,
and you,
UK,
there's quite a few I guess,
but at a recent summit of the 20 largest economies,
the United States was isolated,
you know,
doesn't want to participate in the Paris agreement and so on.
It's just one word for it would be silly,
but another one would be deeply concerning.
That's two words,
but it's like,
it's like,
uh,
no.
And what would he,
what do you think that the path is?
You know,
there's,
there's the science behind the reality,
but then there's also the reality of politics.
The social engineering that maybe needs to be factored in.
How do we get to the place that we need to be?
Well,
climate deniers in this one case,
not so much anti-vaxxers uh,
a number of climate deniers are almost universally old.
They're almost all older people over 50 years old,
67 years old.
People who control a lot of the money.
And,
uh,
when those people age out,
as the saying goes,
the,
uh,
the other expression for that as die.
Then the young people,
if you've ever seen the map,
maybe you guys generate it,
it was survey monkey.
There's a map of the electoral college have only millennials had voted,
and it's overwhelming overwhelmingly the other way on social issues,
especially climate change.
So I think climate change deniers who are affiliated with conservative parties,
uh,
are very much aware of that.
And so there's,
there's a big hustle to get a very conservative judges put in place in the
Supreme Court.
And to maintain this denial as long as possible,
to get as many regulations turned over as possible,
as quickly as possible.
But when you guys get to be the majority of the voting of the electorate,
this will all have to be reversed and it will happen.
But for people like me,
uh,
my life will suck a little bit near the end.
But you guys,
your lives will really star because once,
once the,
the carbon dioxide methane stuff are in the atmosphere,
they just don't get 'em out.
You know,
carbon dioxide last couple hundred years,
it's,
it's cycle is about five years,
but it gets replaced by another carbon dioxide molecule.
And that it's going to go on for a couple of hundred years.
The analogy is a,
you have a roast in the oven or a Turkey in the oven or wood.
I know.
Okay.
This is use your imagination and vegans.
Just imagine
after you take it out of the oven,
the heat still working its way into the middle for a long time and that's what's
going to happen to the earth.
So we want to get to work on climate change as fast as we can.
How much time do we have?
Well,
everybody argues about that.
There are people will be around indefinitely.
You can't kill humans.
They're crazy.
You want to have the highest quality of life for as many people as possible.
You know you don't want Santa Monica beach is cool.
Why Barry?
Why put it underwater?
Right?
Come on.
Can I read a passage from your book?
What if I said no?
We'll go to the next question.
The whole thing?
Yeah.
Try it out loud.
Come on.
unbelief.com didn't let him marry outside the roof off to dump blasted.
So you write a lot of people.
A lot of what I've done over the past four decades,
including writing the book that you're reading now was inspired by the need to
help people understand what it means to be a global species.
The challenge is taking responsibility for our actions,
assuming deliberate control of the change.
We're all in this together.
Nerds don't give up when there's a problem to be solved,
and so I've kept working on my climate message.
We doubling my efforts to try everything all at once.
Yes.
What have you been doing?
It is,
it is.
And thank you for that.
And what,
what,
what have you been doing all at once?
Like this has really been your,
your life?
Well,
I come here,
I wrote another book,
which takes time.
I don't know if you've tried it
and I go to college campuses,
I speak,
I go to the US Congress,
I go to the astronautical congress,
which is a huge party of rocket people.
And we talk about climate change and bill bill's big three clean water,
renewable electricity and access to the Internet.
And for example,
at the astronautical Congress to provide access to the Internet.
In the developing world will almost certainly involve what we call space assets,
what other people call satellites and they're going to have to be in low earth
orbit,
you know,
a constellation of a few hundred of them and they'll hand off the Internet a
service from one to the other.
Uh,
the way we do with mobile phone calls,
and this is all seems to be doable,
but doing it at a reasonable cost and who's going to pay for it and who benefits
and so on and so on.
So these are issues that we can solve that you guys,
especially with the efficiency of the Internet,
are going to be a huge part of,
and I appreciate it,
man.
Woman.
Yeah.
So Kim,
can you let,
let's switch gears a little bit.
Um,
to switch gears.
Older reference,
electronic
go off with,
many of you may have bicycle
fixed,
he's not singles.
These are your shift 17 speed,
21 speed.
You talk a lot about the nerd mindset
and really I know nothing about it and embracing it.
Yes.
He sought a fixie.
It's,
you know,
it's a 17 speed 21 sweet.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I'm sorry.
So what is the nerd mindset?
How do you show everybody's passionate about something,
right?
You guys had Google especially,
there's some thing that when you're in the business,
right,
there's something that you think is cool and you're passionate about.
We want to get everybody to harness that passion,
to accomplish great things,
to save the world for humans.
You know,
I remind her of what the Earth's going to be here.
No matter what we do,
I want to save it for me,
the human,
we're in the sixth extinction,
you know,
this is all very serious biz.
We are now not just the ancient dinosaurs who were killed by the asteroid.
We are also the asteroid or on both ends of this thing.
So we can,
we can change,
we have freewill or nominally we have free will certainly have the ability to
reason.
So,
uh,
I want everybody to harness their nerdiness and make the world better.
And my claim for your evaluation is it,
the people who wrote the u s constitution were nerds.
They thought it was cool.
We're going to have a brand new government without a king or queen,
what yes,
going to be cool.
And uh,
it'll be like Athens only on a whole continent size scale.
And yes,
to be sure there were some issues,
some issues of people of your ancestry.
Okay.
Uh,
but they were doing the best they could at the time.
I think at the time doing the best they could,
but they were nerves.
They looked at this at running a government,
uh,
with a,
um,
with an analytic or a critical thinking perspective,
you know,
Article One,
section eight U s constitution or first to the progress of science and useful
arts.
That's US people.
Useful arts,
I think in a 18th century speak was engineering,
you know,
making buildings and sewer systems and stuff like that,
the useful arts.
And uh,
now they are you guys,
people have said to Molech and we'll get back to work,
but people have said,
hey,
Bill Nye,
what's the most important invention ever?
And you can tell they want me to say the Google phone,
you know?
But to me the most important invention humans comes up is a sewer.
Absolutely.
You could not have any city like this without a sewer system.
And it takes,
you've got to be thoughtful.
I mean you got to plan on a city size scale.
So Viva La Sueur,
now you talk about the,
the,
the nerd mindset and how it should really be applied to big problems.
And,
and you make a distinction between the,
the big problems in the trivial problems.
Can you talk,
what's a trivial problem?
Like your shoe laces?
See
he has to double knot as
she and the guy next to her
mommy.
Same.
Not the stays here all day.
Doesn't come on.
You'd have to double knockers they'd come and tied,
right?
But they do,
they have the word breaks my heart.
The phrase breaks my heart does not do enough I think just crushes me.
So every day I look out and see the miss tied shoes
and I realized my life's kind of been a waste
now.
Now here's the thing
that's going to close up.
If we can.
Well,
it's just that these are shoe laces or bow tie ins.
Everybody's familiar with this expression and overhead.
Not you won one,
not one.
A wrap around the other string.
If I were to do this,
oh,
it's hard to do.
It's so troubling where you're not goes up and down your shoe like this as yours
does.
When you start,
right,
there's the loads on this nod or uneven there.
Unsymmetrical so this not comes untied readily.
Yes.
It's heartbreaking.
Yes,
it sucks.
But what you want is for the not to be square,
symmetrical.
No.
Notice if I pull these a breath or other way,
Bill.
Dude,
if you pull them this way,
you end up with a square.
Not a beautiful symmetrical square.
Not for any sailors here.
This is also called a reef,
not for reefing.
The sales for making the sale smaller and strong.
When I,
it's a real thing.
Reefing is sales a real thing?
We do have a close.
I see.
Yeah.
So this is what you want in your bow is a square bow.
So you're saying that's trivial.
All the shoes walking around the earth.
Miss tide.
Just thinking
I'm okay.
Yes,
lead on Malique,
but by the way,
I think you just created the well will be the number one how to video on
youtube.
This,
this little bump here.
Please get a close up.
We'll wait till you're an up and close.
Maybe they're probably not listening.
That's there are.
There we go.
We got it.
It's an overhand knot,
right?
That's an overhand overhand knot or whatever you want to call it.
One string around the other.
Then you got to make a loop on your shoe can.
We can't really,
we can't do this too fast on your,
you make a loop.
Now whether you do it this way or make bunny ears,
it works the same,
but you go around the loop with the other one and then you got to poke that
through to create the other half of the bow.
This is not,
you know,
controversial.
So here,
don't worry about that.
Here you got to make it a loop.
Same idea and then by tradition,
the way I was brought up,
you have this one go over the top that way.
Gravity is helps.
Yeah.
So what if you're in zero gravity?
I seldom
can always hope.
So the key to what you guys,
you have to preserve a place.
So when this is wrapped around your finger,
there's still space there.
And then you push this through,
you know as we do,
there we go.
And so then you have to with any not,
you have to dress the not you have to snug and tight.
It's not magic.
It's not rocket surgery.
You just have to tighten it evenly and then you have it a boat.
And
thank you bill Nye tied,
tied his own.
So then when you have a bow tie,
I don't see a lot of ties here at Google,
but when you lean over,
it doesn't slip into the soup.
It does not flip and flop into your flask.
And so,
uh,
this is the why you wear a bow tie and you watched the Oscars or whatever.
And the guys are all in Tuxedos.
They wear a bow tie once in a while.
A golf show up with a single button cause he's so cool.
Or a black tie on a black shirt with a black,
okay.
Whatever.
When you're dressed up,
you wear black tie and white shirt.
That's,
you don't wear a blue shirt when you're dressed up at a Tuxedo in a Tuxedo and a
[inaudible] everybody,
this is us.
When you're dressed up,
you wear a bow tie.
People that's awesome.
Saying,
uh,
cannot be t dubs as the kids say.
Just this morning Bill Nye saves the world was nominated for two Emmy.
So it's cool.
Don't come running to me.
I'll go.
Although I am one of the writers,
you're only allowed to give to put five names on it.
So we,
I,
we have five names of the,
some of the other writers.
Prashanth Vencat CC pleasance,
Mike Drucker,
uh,
sand and Totten.
And um,
did I mention CC?
I did and I mentioned Mike.
Uh,
I'm fine.
Michael Naidus is not,
nor am I.
We're not on it.
So,
uh,
it's gonna be,
you know,
you don't get,
you don't win the first time,
but it's always cool to be there.
And I'll wear a Tux and I also wear sweaters.
I wear pants,
civics,
everybody there wears pants.
All the guys working ladies don't though.
So we'd love to go on too fast.
Oh,
this is,
this is excellent.
I would love to talk about,
um,
when,
when you grew up,
grew up growing up.
You tell us so many great stories about,
um,
uh,
we're wearing a bow tie and a,
your parents,
your,
your dad,
yeah,
my dad showed me how to tie a bow tie around my leg.
Try it.
This is about the same diameter is your neck,
so you can practice a,
around your leg during one of your Netflix weekends
and,
and your,
your mom was a and an innovator.
She out of college,
I think it was,
um,
went into the military to crack codes.
Yeah.
Well she was recruited.
She was recruited.
So my dad was a couple of years older than my mother was very traditional and he
wanted to build up the nest egg for them in her father would not let them get
married until she was graduated from college.
I mean,
this is in,
my dad went to Johns Hopkins in Baltimore and my mom went to Goucher College,
which used to be the sister school to Hopkins Women Only.
But now they let boys and my mom would say,
you know,
it's gone to help.
But
uh,
she was all women and the,
she'll,
she was,
my dad went before the u s navy had the CBS before that existed,
they hired,
uh,
contractors,
construction firms to do heavy lifting.
So my dad got a job at a construction company on wake island and a,
if you've ever heard of it,
you go to Hawaii and then you go that far again,
another 5,000 nautical miles out in the middle of nowhere.
There's an a toll that's tactically important.
You can refuel a ship there.
And this word,
they used to refuel the flying boats,
the Boeing clipper airplane.
And uh,
anyway,
they were bombed on December 8th,
1941,
which was December 7th in Pearl Harbor.
It's the same day because of the international dateline WIC.
WIC is a beyond the international dateline wind flowing east to west.
And,
um,
so he was a prisoner of war for four years.
If you get a chance to be a prisoner of war,
don't
suck.
But my mom was graduated in 1942 that spring,
her boyfriend and disappeared,
uh,
there,
there were bombed,
the radio was destroyed.
They had no communication.
They didn't have Facebook or youtube or Twitter.
Right.
I know.
Yeah.
What did they do all day?
I don't know.
They did something.
Yeah.
Uh,
and so,
so,
uh,
the head of gout collared,
the dean of students had voucher was Dorothy Stimson who was the first cousin of
Henry Stimson who was the secretary of war.
And this is back in the day,
everybody,
he apparently said to her,
do you any ladies that can come work on this thing?
I can't tell you what it is.
So my mom worked on the enigma code,
which there's notorious thing and World War II and my whole life people would
ask her,
what did you do during the war?
Can't talk about it.
I can't talk about it.
And they had a big party.
They were declassified in 1992 50 freaking years after they were recruited.
And they still wouldn't,
my nephew tried to do a report and they still would,
none of them.
There were seven ladies there at that point.
They would not talk about it.
It was,
uh,
it was the thing.
It was a fang.
Wow.
Wow,
wow.
And then incredible.
Groundbreaker um,
your,
your mom can,
can you talk about her influence on you and say,
Oh yeah.
So my mom,
you know this expression,
teach a man to fish.
My mom was big on teacher,
won't give a woman officially today teach,
teach a woman officially the rest of your life.
I can,
so I can cook,
I can do the dishes.
I have some,
I can vacuum.
I have some competency because she made us learn to do those things.
I still have two sewing machines.
It's more,
but you know,
one of them is really good for zigzag.
I don't have to tell you,
but,
uh,
my ladies,
my mom marched in the equal rights amendment parade in 1973.
Thank you.
Yes,
I didn't do it.
And she tells,
I mean,
she said she threw her bra and the fire.
I don't know if she really did,
but that's what she said she did.
I was not in a position to verify that
this is before the woman's march.
This is 1973,
and that the legacy of those days is with us now.
I mean,
look,
half the employees at Google,
here are women in my parents time.
That was not the case.
You know?
Uh,
there were very,
very,
very few women engineers.
Nobody's,
no women computer coders back then.
Very,
very few.
So,
uh,
she was part of that vanguard and,
and then,
uh,
I get it.
I mean,
I say all the time,
half the humans are women and girls.
So it's half,
half the engineers and scientists,
women what,
what,
you're twice as many brands,
right?
It will be good or braids.
Women are better at everything.
Okay.
All right.
And we sell it.
We planned the hand.
I was dealt with here.
I'm a guy.
All right.
We still have more work to do.
You know,
where I guess we're not,
how do we encourage more diversity?
More women and girls to get into diversity.
I mean Malique I'm checking you out.
I think you've probably been through some things that I can't even imagine,
uh,
on account of your ancestry.
Right.
Nobody just pulls me over driving while Dorky white guy.
So,
uh,
anyway,
we subprocess everybody.
We just gotta stick with it.
You can have high expectations,
but I encourage everybody not to let your fury you get in the way of getting
things done.
You know,
we're all ticked off about something,
not me.
Of course I'm the smooth.
So it's a long journey,
but I guess you support people shouldn't base on merit rather than ancestry or
gender.
That's right.
Well thanks bill.
Yeah,
thanks.
Obvious.
Avi as the kids say Avi.
So Bill Nye
the science guy and then there's Bill Nye the comedy guy.
One in the same.
Sure.
And it's not only on my funny,
I'm what?
Bill leak.
That's right.
Funny.
Yes.
And I thought it was so
interesting,
the comedy.
So can you tell us about your experience in standup comedy?
And so what happened was a guy I would have been freshman roommate with in
college,
I went into mechanical engineering.
He went into material science,
Dave lax and,
but we still stayed in touch.
We've just,
uh,
would go to school and buildings next to each other on the engineering
quadrangle at Cornell.
And one afternoon he comes hurrying to my house.
We live near each other,
uh,
in Ithaca,
New York in this area called college town.
And um,
he came her and you got to see this,
you won't believe this.
You got to come see this.
So he had this crazy new thing.
In 1977,
he had cable television.
Whoa dude.
And so they had on there was running in the rotation was Steve Martin at the
boarding house,
which was a nightclub in San Francis still there.
The boarding house is still a revered,
nice,
like whiskey or Gogo kind of thing.
Been there for years and years.
And uh,
so it was Steve Martin and I went and looked at it and the guy,
he's Dave said,
look,
this guy is just like,
you look at this.
He's just like,
he was sensibility is just like you who showed the slide two,
slide two.
So
there are just,
they're distinguishable.
No.
So then a year later,
Warner brothers records sponsored a Steve Martin lookalike contest.
And by then I'd been recruited by Boeing.
I was living in Seattle,
working in Everett,
Washington for you zip code buffs,
Everett Washington,
right on world's largest volume building where they build at that time,
seven 47.
Now they built seven,
seven,
seven 87.
Uh,
and uh,
so I entered that and I won.
I mean,
I want,
it was,
I claim,
as I told Steve when I met him once,
I haven't met him.
Uh,
I strongly believe that I got what he was driving at in a way that the
contestants did this absurdist view of the world.
I did not win the national one.
That guy was from Nashville.
He could play the Banjo for crying out loud.
Steve Martin,
if you know,
he's well known,
he's won grammys for his banjo playing.
Uh,
but he also kind of looked like him,
which was a step I didn't really take.
So,
uh,
anyway,
after you get laughs,
you know,
it's very,
uh,
inspiring.
It's addicting.
You want to get laughs all the time.
So I started doing standup comedy and then I met some people,
some guys who were being groomed or recruited by the Seattle,
a NBC affiliate station,
k I n.
G.
Um,
Seattle's in King County,
Washington.
And by the way,
it's been retroactively named King County on account of Martin Luther King.
Oh Wow.
Who was was not around in the 1850s,
but a,
it's charming.
Anyway,
they wanted to have a comedy show and so they asked me to be in a couple bits
and it was funny or funny enough.
And then I eventually quit my job after awhile,
October 3rd,
1986 roughly.
And,
um,
and because I,
at that time,
you guys computerated design and a career as a manufacturer,
commuter and machining,
we're just coming on.
It was like this new thing.
Do you guys,
you compete with Katia or do you own them?
You probably own them anyway.
It was new technology and I felt that if I,
uh,
dropped out of engineering,
even for six months,
I wouldn't be able to,
uh,
rejoined,
get back in the,
you know,
Seattle was not silicon valley,
but sort of,
and I worked at Boeing and then,
um,
the company called Sun Strand would makes all the black boxes for airplanes and
which is now Honeywell.
They got bought out.
But,
uh,
I just,
I've took a chance and it worked out.
It just kept making a living and then eventually I,
uh,
I was so I would work part time.
I was one of the last guys as loose as far as I knew on the last guys or work on
a drawing board,
you know,
with uh,
with the led holders or we don't call them pencils.
Oh No.
And um,
electric eraser,
a little racing shield to lay out these big things like this big sheets of paper
to make these tiny instruments.
Sorry.
No,
you'd lay it out 10 to one,
sometimes a hundred to one to make things,
you know,
that are as big as a watch.
You know how the accelerometer in a competitive product can tell you which way
the phone's oriented.
It was the early days of that stuff.
Lithography and very small scale.
So,
uh,
anyway,
it took a long time.
I quit my job in 86 and they started doing the science guy show and we did a
pilot in 1992.
Wow.
So six years of,
you know,
dinking around.
Yeah.
Trying to,
um,
we did the landmark and important video,
fabulous wetlands about how great wetlands are and that was sort of served as a
template for the show with Jim Mckenna and Aaron Gotlieb.
These other producers I fell in with.
Does that answer your question or did you want to take up the whole hour talking
about these details?
This one of your people?
I guess the guy's like six feet tall housing.
Not yet,
but getting there,
he's like five,
10 isn't freezing all lookout,
dad,
look out.
Um,
so you know,
you're,
you're probably one of the only people who have,
uh,
who,
who's gotten advice from both Jerry Seinfeld and Carl Sagan.
Yes,
of course.
I roll with both.
You Roll an interesting circles.
What was the advice that you got from Jerry Seiner?
Oh,
so you guys on his way up sign,
Jerry Seinfeld would come through Seattle on the circuit.
You know,
he'd go,
Portland,
Oregon,
Seattle,
Vancouver,
British Columbia,
San Francisco,
New York,
Chicago.
You know,
uh,
comedians,
comedians still do it anyway,
when he was Nco,
you could,
you could go have brunch with him on Sunday morning at this place,
either at,
there's two Starbucks stores in Seattle that both claimed to be the first one,
uh,
at one of the first Starbucks is you could go there and have coffee with them on
Sunday morning especially.
And he said he liked to dress better than the audience.
That was his advice.
And uh,
you know,
that's,
if you watched the Seinfeld episodes in the beginning,
we had a little standup thing.
He's in a sport coat and tie and a shirt.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you look at Louis C K doesn't adhere to that rule at all,
but I know,
I mean,
he doesn't,
he's a different deal and he's brilliant.
Uh,
so I embrace that.
Then the other thing he said is,
when you're there,
be there.
It's a real,
when you start doing standup comedy,
you're nervous.
You're a afraid that the audience will hate you,
which is very likely.
And so you lose your focus.
You get worried about what they're thinking of you rather than you're hilarious
comedy jokes.
And so that was good advice.
Those two little scraps of advice I have,
Helen,
I attributed to Mr Seinfeld.
He was very nice to us,
to all of us.
Uh,
you know,
it'd be young guys that he's 10 years older than I am kind of thing,
and maybe he's less than that.
Well,
and he's a huge success,
you.
And so,
uh,
but those are two really good pieces of advice.
Let let,
let's,
I would love to talk about space and space.
Huge fans.
How many people are members?
The plan chairside?
Anybody?
Oh,
I suck.
Thank you.
Yes.
So considered check us out of planetary.org.
Right,
right.
Dancing,
space science and exploration.
That's right.
So,
so that's your day job,
so,
right.
Can you talk about your day job is CEO of the Planetary Society.
So you guys,
I,
you know,
I worked for a lot of people and I make lots of jokes about my old boss.
None of the jokes are flattering,
but my old boss and what an idiot he was.
But there is no one old boss.
It's an amalgam.
You all work for fabulous bosses and you're always happy and no,
there's no conflict here at Google news new.
Yes.
Uh,
but now I'm in charge of,
you know,
a couple of few dozen people,
30 people and I've learned a lot.
You,
uh,
you want to work with people who are sharing the objective so that you're all
trying to do the same thing and you want to work people that are competent but a
competency is not all that difficult to come by.
It's getting the chemistry,
getting the people together that can produce.
And so I've learned a lot doing that.
But what we want to do and at the planetary society is advance space science and
exploration.
I submit to you,
we are living at a time when we made discover life on another world.
And if we were to find life on another world,
it would change the course of human history.
It would be like Copernicus showing the earth goes around the sun instead of the
other way around.
Or Galileo,
you know the,
I know the moon looks like a perfect circle,
but if you take this telescope,
you can see it's full of bumps.
Well,
we're going to have to imprison you.
I know,
but it's still full of bumps.
I'm sorry man.
And uh,
you have to stay home the rest of your life.
Okay?
Whatever.
Still bumps.
And so if we found life on Mars,
for example,
or stranger still on Europa,
the moon of Jupiter with twice as much seawater is the earth and would change
everything.
I mean,
I'm not saying,
I said [inaudible] not saying we'd suddenly drive on the left in the u s are not
going to change everything,
but it would change the way everybody feels about being alive in the cosmos.
And so that's what the planetary society does.
I was just at the planetary protection meeting.
So it's the prime directive,
you know,
you don't want to take human germs to Mars and contaminated so that you can't
tell if there ever were any marsh and germs before you got there.
And it's a big,
it's a nontrivial issue,
you know,
getting spacecrafts sterile enough to do that and to get it with instruments
that will detect something alive.
You know.
How do you know if it's alive or was,
is it a fossilized Matt of ancient Mars crow bacteria things or what have you
and who's going to pay for it?
That's our business.
I go to the U S Congress a couple of times a year and hey this would be great
man.
I say I paraphrase uh,
Mr Congressman.
I think so.
The other thing about space exploration that's really charming and wonderful.
It brings out the best in us.
It really does.
You guys know Adam Schiff is,
he's on the news all the time right now cause he's the head of the intelligence
committee.
Some issue with Russia and some people,
some things,
but he's also a huge supporter of exploring Europa because he's a big supporter
of the jet propulsion lab in Pasadena.
And then there's John Culberson from the Houston area who explained to me that
really the safest place bill and probably in the country is the Texas State
House.
And build what you do,
get your concealed weapons permit and get in the concealed weapons line.
Shortest line bill,
much fast.
You get,
everybody's got a weapon,
nothing's going to happen there,
you know,
give him Mr Culberson.
Yes.
Anyway,
he and Adam Schiff disagree about almost everything except the exploration of
Europa.
And they work to fund it all the time to go up what's so called flagship mission
over a billion dollar mission,
$4 billion mission.
Our mission is a space talk for rocket ship thing,
mission.
It's a mission.
It's what it is.
You mean it's a satellite?
Yeah,
yeah.
Whatever.
Uh,
but the mission involves all the people on the ground and so on.
But they agree on this.
And I say to everybody,
in the case of us where we are right now,
uh,
NASA is the best brand.
The United States has theirs.
You can meet people in other parts of world and hate the u s they hate me,
that hate everything,
but they respect NASA.
And so that alone is a worthy investment of our intellect and treasure.
So I encourage you all to check out the planetary society.
Is My briefcase over there.
Susan.
Susan's from Rodale.
Press the company that printed the books.
Thank you,
Susan.
Yes,
hang on.
This will be worth it.
I injured my leg.
I'm a mess.
Hey,
my microphone works way over here.
Thanks electronics.
So,
uh,
this is a thing we want you to check out for the eclipse.
So that's my phone.
Is that good to throw them on the floor?
Uh,
there's the planetary study logo.
Wow.
Thanks bill.
Is it a ringed planet or is it the letter P for planetary?
Wait,
it's both.
So these are eclipse glasses.
So,
uh,
you can't see a thing when you look right at the light.
You see anything,
right?
Adam?
No.
Huh?
Uh,
nothing that ECL to anyway,
so these are for sale checkout.
I like you.
There's a woman owned business I've done business with for many years.
Teacher source.com.
Uh,
and the company's called education innovations and the market.
And if for those of you,
is there anybody here who does not have a bill Nye bobblehead
wow.
It's so weird.
Anyway,
you also get those
education innovations.
And so August 21st,
there will be a clips going right across the world's third most populous
country.
And I encourage all of you to get out there and get under it.
If you've never seen a total eclipse,
it really is crazy.
It's an amazing experience.
And uh,
it probably,
it's very reasonable for most of us.
It'll be a once in a lifetime thing because although there are two eclipses
every two years due to the,
of the planets and Sun except theirs,
it's in space.
There's no sound.
So,
uh,
most of them are not over accessible land.
That's easy for people in the u s to get to.
So a really encourage you,
you drive somewhere and get under it and then you can make it a day trip.
You know,
you can fly to Omaha,
drive out under the eclipse and then go back to the airport and come back.
I mean,
you don't have to rent a cabin in the woods for two years.
I mean just go out there or if you're in the Atlanta area and just get an in
Portland,
Oregon.
But I recommend you get east of the mountains.
If you know your way around the northwest because west of the mountain,
there's a good chance you'll get weathered out.
As we say.
If it's cloudy,
you don't see anything and it really is amazing.
The Sky goes dark,
you can see stars.
I'm hoping this one's going to be real and you're,
you're,
you're going to get the ring around the sun.
We're hoping to see these interference bands,
you know,
the wavelengths of light make these gray bands go sweeping across the landscape
is crazy.
Really is some I've seen one.
Yeah,
good one.
When I was in South Africa for a meeting and it's really something,
I've been near a couple of them,
but really being under it this cool August 21st,
August 21st.
Don't miss it if you can.
And uh,
if you don't want to spend all that money on the plastic ones,
there's paper and they're okay.
Uh,
and they're also branded for Bill Nye and uh,
oh yeah.
You can see dimly.
Yeah.
You can see the LEDs,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
So a little bit,
these modern lights,
uh,
are,
they're no longer a single filament or a carbon arc and anything,
go ahead.
There's a mixture of a little dots,
right?
Is this,
is this your son here?
One of these people and we have one of them come up.
Yeah.
What's her name?
Do you know?
John Henry.
So try those on.
Oh,
look at you and look at the lights.
Do you see the mini colored dots?
Yeah,
I have eye witness.
Yes.
All right.
Nicely done.
Can I hold onto those?
I only got one.
All right.
So we're,
we're,
we're gonna.
That's awesome.
And we're going to go take questions from the audience and if we can go to slide
six slide as we go to
audience questions,
I've got a question for the audience.
What do Bill Nye,
Rihanna,
Jennifer Lawrence and Elon Musk have in common
that week?
Somebody said money.
Sorry.
So not yet.
After we sell a few dozen of these plastic glasses,
you,
you are listed as one of the top celebrities along with the other three in the
plural generation who are the generation of 13 to 20.
Um,
uh,
some things,
yes.
Uh,
you're,
you're up there with those three.
So I'm considered a celebrity among people that age.
That's smell
found as a celebrity among people of that age.
If you go,
if I go to a Starbucks in order a vanilla latte,
it's $4.
Without that,
I tastic thing.
All right,
questions from the audience.
I'm going to throw you this thing if you want to ask questions.
Um,
because it has a microphone in it and it's a thing.
The blue thing.
Yeah,
we can throw it.
It won't hurt you.
It's foamy.
Oh,
it's in her,
the ball cube.
Yes.
So you roll it on the floor and see who picks it up.
Let's just try that.
Not so fast.
Yeah,
he was making story real quick before I throw this at people.
Uh,
we do have a bookseller right up side.
We have subsidized copies of the book you've been hearing about.
So please buy one if you want to read it.
Who has a question?
And I signed them,
right?
Those are the ones that we did yesterday.
Yeah,
I signed 550 of them yesterday.
Awesome.
Took a few minutes and we can move off this slide with the fountain pen.
If you're buying a book.
I love you man.
Showing some respect.
Yes.
So we have a question.
Hi,
I'm Julian.
Why are you raise your hand wave or their yard?
The blue thing?
Yes.
Um,
what do you think that the government's role in science should be and what do
you think it has been historically?
Well,
historically the government,
our government anyway,
as supported science,
basic research,
mostly at universities.
And then it trickles down.
And then we have a whole thing or we used to call the Department of Education
Studies,
which studies how people learn and support schools,
public schools,
which I attended.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we reason we invest in science is to stay competitive,
to innovate competitive and two ways economically on the world stage.
Uh,
you know,
when people made fun of him.
But when you build interstate highways that enabled people to come to work at
Google,
that is support as a form of supporting science.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
the other thing is in national defense,
weapons are almost all continually being innovated,
being a modified and improved and made more effective.
And the big thing,
nominally until recently,
the big thing was to have cool weapons,
not used them.
And that was the big idea.
But
it's getting weird peoples,
it's getting weird.
So,
uh,
government in my opinion,
should invest in science and that's what keeps everybody competitive.
There's a whole thing,
you know where I was on the TV the other day with the uh,
Grover Norquist guy who says he wants to shrink the government and drowned in a
bathtub.
I don't think that's what you really want.
Like,
um,
after that we just drive on either side of the street.
Is that okay?
And no stop lights.
Cool.
Really Fun.
No fire departments.
You sure about that?
So what happens with those guys in general?
They've talked a good game until push comes to shove until the sewer backs up,
until the military's not funded,
then they freak out.
So uh,
supporting basic research is very important and whatever innovations you all can
do,
uh,
to help everybody,
all the internet or information technology people around the world.
Thank you.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah,
but thank you so much.
Saying something like that and doing it is doing things.
Let's throw the mic.
I think we've got a question over here and I want to see it through it.
Cause it,
yes,
there you go.
You could have played pro ball.
Yeah.
So since we know you're an advocate of the non useful arts,
what would be your advice to those who pursue those as a Christian non useful
art?
Well,
you were making that joke that the founding fathers were referring to useful
arts as engineering and science and but at nighttime century or the 18th
century,
I mean I don't think they had the word engineering.
It wasn't used the way we use it today.
Well,
I guess then just to clarify,
the question would be what would be your advice for those who are pursuing like
comedy or music production arts,
uh,
in a,
in a world where that's,
that's more predominantly focused on math,
science,
engineering,
like you know,
as,
as our government's clearly are winnowing and sifting towards that direction for
people who are in the creative fields.
What would be your advice I guess is my,
is do it,
that's my,
just get started.
That's my advice.
And do you feel like they are just as important as those other fields?
You can't have a world without art.
Okay.
Everybody are improves your life.
We are in this architecture did space that the brings out emotions make you feel
a certain way.
Yes.
You got to have art.
So what's going on?
So,
okay.
All right.
Everything's fine.
I grew up with the space program.
People my age had the space program.
So science was imbued,
was embedded in society.
It was just part of what went on every day along with this crazy optimism that
science scientists and engineers could solve any problem.
We're going to go to the moon.
We're going to do this.
The Apollo program was 4% of the federal budget.
NASA's budget now is 0.4%.
It was literally 10 times as big.
So science was just in,
I was just around all the time.
Cars had fins on them,
like rockets,
not for any utilitarian purpose,
just to remind us all of our cool rockets were.
And uh,
and then so that effort was,
that was really a informal form of warfare.
When that was resolved,
this sorta went away.
So now there's been this emphasis on stem,
stem,
science,
technology,
engineering and math,
stem,
stem school,
stem wing,
stem teachers.
Stem using video manager and then people quite reasonable.
He said,
well,
what about art?
So now their steam,
right?
Science,
technology,
engineering,
art and math.
Then I've come from time to time.
I meet steam,
science,
technology,
engineering,
art,
math and design.
Okay.
Pretty soon we're going to call it school.
It's
just
the pendulum's going to swing.
You do not want a world without art,
for crying out loud,
but you do not want a world without science.
So,
all right.
That's what happened.
My interpretation,
which as you know is correct.
Questions in the back,
really his interpreter?
Yes.
Bill eyes,
correct?
Yes.
Hello,
Eric,
you're ready to go?
Perfect.
I love Wine Cube,
Mike.
So my question is around engaging climate deniers.
Uh,
in this crowd you are largely preaching to the choir.
most of us have friends where we're preaching to the choir.
What can you suggest for us to engage people to make a difference instead of
just talking to people who agree with us?
Well,
so I sell a time,
talk about it and ask people why they don't believe the world's climate is
changing.
And most people you meet really are nervous about it.
That's my experience.
Climate deniers are nervous about it.
I was on the radio this morning in Miami,
Florida,
and there are just,
everybody's talking about it.
The tides are higher every year.
Every full moon,
the tides are higher,
but the called King tides and when the,
when there's a low pressure system,
it shows up in Florida on the sort of the nine o'clock side of a
counterclockwise weather system.
Then the tides are even higher,
you know,
so called a storm surge and they're all talking about it.
Norfolk,
Virginia,
Galveston,
Texas.
They're all talking about it,
so if you keep talking about it,
eventually things will change.
I don't think the u s government will be able to keep most stay in denial.
I just think it all,
they'll run out of steam,
the steam,
the professionals that the environmental protection agency and us geologic
survey and the weather service or just not going to put up with us.
Eventually they'll,
things will turn around just who we want it to be as fast as possible.
Right.
My wishfully thinking.
Yeah,
Scott Pruitt.
Really,
the head of the EPA is the guy who wanted to shut down the EPA.
Really?
Rick Scott,
the governor of Wisconsin won't see the word evolution.
I'm Scott Walker won't say evolution.
Rick Scott,
the governor of Florida,
forbidden tried to forbid anybody from using the phrase climate change in
meetings of legislators.
Oh,
that'll do it.
Yeah.
That's all you gotta do is just not talk about it.
She was,
these are real people running a real country.
It's amazing.
Let's get the cube.
Let's take out one or two more questions.
Yes.
Oh,
please.
Yeah,
sorry.
Um,
first of all,
I loved your show as I was growing up as a kid.
I love it.
Thank you,
man.
This is awesome.
I just wanted to know,
uh,
besides science,
if you were involved with the,
uh,
the making of your theme song that so iconic though,
Bill,
Bill Bread.
Sorry.
I mean,
I did the voice,
uh,
science as a property of matter.
I mean,
I,
yeah,
I did the lip sync.
I mean,
but I was involved.
But the guy did was named uh,
Jim Green and he has a company called 38 fresh.
He was a producer here in Los Angeles.
He's a good guy.
Were there any different versions that you had to choose from for the show when
you had
it's there?
Were you guys who was 23 years ago?
I don't remember any.
I mean,
if there were different versions,
they might be some scratch tracks that were sort of the same thing that a
different beats per minute,
but it's just no,
and then,
you know,
Tyler,
the Creator did the song for a Bill Nye saves or saved the wound.
He's a good guy that hung out with him one morning and he's,
he's funny guy and a,
we're going to have him on the new show.
We start shooting again on Tuesday.
Yes,
sorry.
12 more shows.
So he tried to make it or he did make a derivative of the old song.
But I don't sing the songs.
Everybody know that.
You hire that out.
The example I give you all,
even if you're a not of an age,
Gilligan's island,
Gilligan doesn't sing the song.
So Bill Nye doesn't sing the song of his own show.
There's one exception by Brian Broadcast History,
Fraser,
uh,
Kelsey Grammer saying the phrase or song,
not the scrambled eggs.
Yeah,
I know.
Let's do one more question.
I thought was Fraser was a derivative bit from cheers.
Okay.
Jimmy burrows.
Yes.
It's more you need the boom Mike,
the house of blue mix.
Yeah.
I guess I have the,
so I just kind of wanted to follow up a little more on the question.
Um,
the gentleman with the beard asked before about essentially like
when you,
I guess like I think it's uncontroversial,
but like you're,
you're not really like a stranger to debates,
debates that are controversial.
Um,
and I guess I find that like,
I don't know,
sometimes I'll argue as people who I sort of like radically disagree with,
um,
and it kind of quickly becomes clear that like,
in no way is it going to be fruitful.
Um,
for example,
you know,
like I,
I know all these people who are like,
right wing populist extremists from like my hometown in Tennessee.
And like you like talk to them about immigration and you're like,
well,
what about the human cost of that ridiculous policy are proposing?
And they're like,
oh yeah.
Well what about the human cost of what Hillary Clinton did it Libya?
And I'm just kinda curious like,
to what extent do you think it's worth like engaging with people with whom you
like radically disagree?
Oh,
I think it's worth engaging.
What happens?
You know,
it's wherever the cities are big enough to have people cross paths.
They get over this immigration thing.
Uh,
it's,
I think that'll shake itself out.
Just these are smaller,
like Saint Louis is an interior city.
It's not a coastal city.
Minneapolis is not a coastal city.
But you'll find that the people have lawsuits of the state legislature,
the state attorney generals have lawsuits against this policy because they,
the big cities have diversity and you do business with your neighbors and you
just kind of,
my understanding is you get over it.
So just challenge your friends to travel.
Uh,
you go to New York,
it's a real place.
There are fewer murders per day in New York than any major metropolitan city
because the city kind of freaked out after nine 11.
There's a cop on every corner and you never get lost in New York cause you can
ask directions of all the cops on the corner.
It's fabulous.
Uh,
and uh,
encourage them to go to Paris and see what people are like,
wow.
People eat food.
Cool.
Did Not know that.
And,
uh,
you,
I think it's just we got to get along.
And when you all do at Google is democratize the Internet,
you know,
democratize,
uh,
interactions,
social interactions.
So that's,
it's a long process,
but I encourage you to engage people about anything like that.
And uh,
as far as immigration policies,
it is
okay.
No answer.
Uncles,
no grandparents can really have you thought this through.
So we'll see what happens.
I don't think that policy will last because the court system I think is robust
enough,
but we'll see what happens.
You know,
I tell everybody,
I remember when Nixon resigned,
I'm that old and it took a year and a half for all of that stuff to catch up
with them.
So we'll see what happens in the coming months.
Well,
maybe nothing will happen.
My idea,
can you talk quite quickly about your,
your um,
national service idea?
Oh yeah.
My national service,
I,
this is great.
So bill,
you chose not to join the military and you've got an opinion.
Yeah,
so people my age,
the reason I did not go to Vietnam was because basically I'm six months too
young.
I missed getting drafted by six months.
I,
I had to register for the draft and your height and weight and everything and
you get ready to be enlisted and stuff.
But then the draft was abolished right before I was born in November.
I went to kindergarten when I was four,
so I didn't turn 18 until my senior year in high school.
So I missed the draft by a few months.
But my older brother's friends were deeply affected by the Vietnam war in a bad
way.
But nevertheless,
because of my parents' experience with the military,
my dad was like many years later,
was declared a veteran because they had served with marines and prison of war
camp.
Uh,
I looked into air force ROTC and I wanted to fly jets.
I thought that would be cool.
I went to get my physical and there were a bunch of pilots sitting there and in
the air force base in Rome,
New York for you,
a rural New York buffs.
And I said,
how often do you guys fly?
Oh,
every six weeks.
Sometimes every two months.
What do you do the rest of the time?
Oh,
we memorize procedures.
Uh Wow.
It doesn't sound like much fun.
So I did not join the military,
but if I had been required to,
I certainly would have.
So my proposal is that we have a national service or akin to the Americorps,
akin to the peace corps,
or everybody had to join.
So in my parent's day,
everybody,
my parents age,
when they would meet at any situation,
waiting in line at the grocery store when they would go out dancing,
when they go out to dinner.
At a restaurant when they'd,
um,
uh,
pick up kids at school.
What they all talked about was what they did during the War World War II because
this thing was such a big deal.
It bound everybody together,
people of faiths,
of all a ancestry.
We're all in this thing together.
So my proposal is that we have a national service that you have to complete
before you turn 26.
And then we would all be involved in the,
if you join the military,
that would count of course for your national service.
It would be involved here domestically or maybe overseas,
all in this thing together.
And yes,
yes,
crazy uncle bill.
It would have to be paid for it tax dollars.
Ah,
ah,
but we would get infrastructure built,
we would get schools connected to the Internet for example,
and everybody would be required to do it.
And we'd all take it for granted that we had to do it.
And I think it would bind us together and ultimately save money.
And we wouldn't have this red state,
blue state,
horrible division that we're nurturing or,
uh,
or end up with right now.
And it's a crazy idea,
but the idea is you could,
if you wanted to,
you could finish college undergraduate before you did your national service.
If you like.
My Dad didn't think law school,
it sounded like all that much fun.
You would do your national service right after that.
If you are obsessed and crazy,
like a few of you are crazy,
just very interested in your academic success and you wanted to get your phd,
you would take your national service after you got your master's degree,
before you went back for your phd.
That's my proposal bill.
That'll never fly.
Everybody hates each other.
We don't want to spend any more tax dollars.
I know.
Okay,
so what if each state had a state service in California?
State service would kind of put pressure on Nevada to have a Nevada state
service and an Arizona state service.
Oregon would sure as heck put pressure on Washington devastate service and then
maybe this could become a national service.
It's a proposal.
It's a little crazy.
I'm glad you asked about it,
but the idea is that we'd all have a common purpose so we wouldn't have,
you know,
there was 15 minutes after nine 11 where everybody was raw,
raw us in a constructive way,
uh,
as horrible as that was.
And so the national services,
just one of my cookie little ideas.
Great.
That's great.
It could be.
We're going to wrap with,
um,
some quick rapid fire question.
Oh yes.
Lightening Round.
Naming your favorite teacher.
Uh,
Mr. Lang.
Physics 11th grade.
Uh,
they don't get me,
I mean,
not that I didn't like Mr. Morrison and this rush.
Okay.
One of your feet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
Mr. Lawrence and sixth grade freaking changed my life.
One of your favorite characters from fiction.
Look,
slow.
Captain Kirk,
Captain Kirk.
You can be an animal for a day.
Well,
I am an animal,
you know,
successful Pelican or something.
Don't want to get eaten.
Know you want to be the tour.
You've worked with a lot of great educational youtube burrs.
One one that you really enjoyed working with.
Physics Girl Diane.
Oh yeah,
she's great.
Great [inaudible] calendar alleys.
Great.
And Derek Mauer ver very tazia.
He's really great.
He's a good guy.
Fantastic self driving car or human powered bike.
Well human powered bike.
If the distances are suitable,
I mean it's self driving car.
If I live in studio city,
it's 2123 miles to get here.
I mean,
yeah,
you could do it,
but then I got to go to San Diego this afternoon.
You have to be a heck of an athlete.
I'm sure I could do it.
And the self driving car,
you guys,
I think about my grandfather went into world war one on a horse.
Nobody went into World War Two on a horse.
Nobody was serious about it.
I mean it would want,
wanted to live through it.
So everything changed in 25 years.
Everything changed.
So why you don't I learn,
I can drive a stick shift.
Great.
That end four bucks will get you the Latte,
you know what I mean?
It's just a skill you don't need anymore.
And then the last one for the win,
potential energy or kinetic energy.
Okay.
There.
You know,
you exchange one for the other.
I want to be in motion if you can.
There we met up.
Let's all give it up.
Bill Nye.
Thank you so much.
[inaudible] somebody can hold up the book.
Let's get a close up of the book.
You got to check out the book.
Please buy the book.
It's a great read.
Thank you very much.